Democrat mayor Michelle woo has just
invited some members of the Boston
government to a Christmas party she's
only invited some of them because the
Christmas party is for non-white people
so white people are not allowed to go
the only reason the white people found
out about this is because city council
relations director Denise dos Santos
accidentally sent an email to All City
Council Members inviting them to the
electeds of color holiday party
right off the bat you know it's it's a
bad it's a bad thing holiday part what's
the holiday what holiday are we
celebrating is it Quanza that's not a
real holiday virtually no one celebrates
Quanza it was a contrivance of a uh
woman beating torturing socialist
lunatic named uh molana kenga his real
name is Ron Everett but during the Black
Power movement he renamed himself Milana
kenga and then he imprisoned women and
put soldering irons on them and hit them
on the head with toasters and
electrocuted them and did all sorts of
terrible things anyway he invented K
Quanza as a socialist holiday and
virtually no one celebrates it so it's
not Kwanza is it Hanukkah Hanukkah is a
minor Jewish holiday it has been
elevated in America to to be a bigger
holiday than it traditionally had been
in Judaism but only to make it the kind
of Jewish version of Christmas but it's
just not Jews have many more significant
holidays at different times of the year
Quanza is or Hanukkah rather is not not
that big a deal it's it's Christmas is
the holiday
but the libs can't say Christmas because
they hate Christianity and and True
Religion so they and and tradition and
you know apple pie and hot dogs and and
anything American at all that
traditionally our
civilization likes so it's the electeds
of color holiday party and here's the
email on behalf of Mayor Michelle woo I
cordially invite you to the electeds of
color holiday party on Wednesday
December 13th at 5:30 p.m. at the
Parkman house 33 Beacon
Street some white people receive this
they say hold on wait what the electeds
of color do I and she then she follows
up she goes hey I wanted to apologize
for my previous email regarding the
holiday party for tomorrow oh notice she
doesn't call it the elected of color
holiday party oh yikes the whites found
out about the the uh electeds of color
party okay no it's the holiday party for
tomorrow I did send that to everyone by
accident I apologize if my email may
have offended or came across as so now
this email is
almost not coherent English well it's
not in coherent English it's almost
impossible to interpret you can tell
this person was flustered oh yikes uh
sorry if this may have offended or came
across as so as what huh as offensive or
I don't know sorry for any confusion
this may have
caused then at this point what should
happen is Mayor woo should come out and
fire this person and mayor W should come
out and say this holiday party holiday
party is completely unacceptable and
we're not going to to exclude whites
from government functions and we're not
going to legally discriminate against
white people anymore than we already do
which is to a pretty significant degree
no what did mayor woo do she defended
it she said Hey Now white people get to
go to plenty of parties this one though
no whites allowed this this government
party no whites are
allowed yeah sorry you shouldn't have
gotten the email hope you weren't
offended it's that classic you know you
don't apologize for for what you did
that was wrong you apologize for someone
else feeling offended I'm sorry if you
felt offended no the issue isn't the
email the issue isn't the feeling of
offense the issue is the party and it's
the party not because someone wants to
go to another government or work
function Christmas party a lot of people
don't want to do that at all it's it's
because the party is a symbol of
anti-white hatred which is the most
widespread and Powerful form of racism
in the entire country
that's the
issue so much so that the Supreme Court
finally had to address the issue and
this year knocked down so-called
affirmative action in one narrow case
that would be in the case of Harvard
discriminating against white and Asian
students and the only reason it worked
is because that they could highlight the
the discrimination against Asians had it
only been a matter of discriminating
against white people the case would have
gone nowhere it is perfectly politically
acceptable it is politically encouraged
to insult white people and to legally
discriminate against them that's it's
encouraged the the leftist social
Engineers the the racial grievance
mongers they screwed up in affirmative
action by also discriminating against
Asians which gave those of us who don't
want cast systems of racial
discrimination uh the opportunity to go
in and say hold on now listen those
nasty terrible evil white people that's
obviously totally fine to discriminate
against them they're the devil they're
the worst people that ever lived but
what about the Asians and then finally
that was enough to get the Supreme Court
to to change it but but it it remains a
major issue and so here you you see a
Democrat mayor of a city getting caught
in in a really just ugly form of racial
discrimination and race hatred clearly
and what does she do she doubles down
doubles down not going anywhere anytime
soon folks but it's not a good look now
when you want to look good you got to
check out Jus cell right now go to
genucell.com there is a lot to be
stressed about during the Christmas
season well stress and lack of sleep can
easily cause those pesky under eye bags
good news is you never have to worry
about that when you have genell skincare
from now until Christmas genus cell's
most popular package has a special
discount just for our listeners at
genucell.com
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin redness and even a sagging
jawline will disappear right before your
eyes with genus cell's most popular
collection genus cell promises immediate
effects you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed or your money
back jell made Christmas come early this
year they sent down a ton of products
for the entire office everyone Raves
about their under eye cream it works
wonders plus included in every most
popular package is your free hyaluronic
acid serum for skin hydration and
restoration I love the company it's
absolutely fabulous the founders a
Coptic Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream he uses the absolute top
ingredients that you can possibly use
and your first order is often discounted
because he knows that you are going to
stick around as a customer for a very
very long time like me genus cell is
simple easily Satisfied by the very best
of everything go to Jus cell.com
canw to get this incredible Christmas
discount every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping Jus
cell.com
today right now go to pre-born docomo
Christmas season is upon us we call it
Advent then we're looking forward to the
end of the year when you make all your
donations and if you are not sure what
to give I will tell you give the gift of
life through this Show's partnership
with pre-born pre-born is an
organization that has rescued over
270,000 babies from abortion by offering
abortion-inducing
a mother's ultrasound pre-born also
supports mothers by providing them with
diapers car seats counseling and more
every day pre-or network of clinics
rescues 200 babies as they compete
head-to-head with the abortion Giants
now through a match your tax deductible
gift is doubled your donation offers
double the blessings now is the time to
put your year-end write-offs to work
have your donation matched today by
dialing pound 250 and saying the keyword
baby that is pound 250 or donate
securely at preborn docomo kwes that is
pre-born docomo pre-born fundraises for
its administrative costs separately so
every dollar you give is going to go
toward saving babies give today
preborn speaking of Democrats and
Christmas while I was gone this is a
little old but I have to cover I have to
get to this story just because I missed
a few shows last week while I was traing
through the subcontinent does not mean
that we're going to miss this the White
House released a really weird Christmas
video it's been totally polarizing
here's the
[Music]
video
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
so if you're just listening to this now
there's not all that much to describe
it's you can hear the tap dancing going
on lot of extremely colorful outfits and
personalities one one might confuse the
White House here for the Senate
Judiciary hearing
room and you know as one might expect
from the Democrats who put such a focus
on race and racial diversity you know
it's uh
you know to to totally out of Central
casting in that regard I kind of like
the video I kind of like it let me just
say kind of here because it's not a good
video but the reason it's not good is
not because of the concept of the video
I really like the concept of it I like
to focus on tap dancing tap dancing is a
really fun wholesome art form very
traditional American art
form the reason the video is not good is
because it it's not good tap
dancing it's not I don't mind the
colorful costumes are a little weird
they're they're a little on the
flamboyant Democrat side but whatever I
don't really care about that the
extremely on the- noose diversity
casting is I I have no problem with
people of all walks of life tap dancing
it's it's on the nose the Democrats are
always just so uh conspicuous about this
sort of thing but again I don't that
doesn't bother me in the least some of
some of my favorite tap dancers are
black guys you know Gregory Hines or
Sammy Davis Jr the reason it's bad tap
dancing gets to an issue at the heart of
leftist
politics which is that it's too
self-indulgent good really good tap
dancing is subtle it's understated it's
elegant you think of people like Fred a
stair you think of people like Jean
Kelly when they when they tap Dan or
Gregory Hines or Sammy Davis Jr any of
any of these other tap dancers that I've
mentioned or not mentioned
their really beautiful tap dancing is
when you can hardly see the moves and
you just hear the Click Click you know
and it's it's just elegant it's graceful
their feet are moving at you know a
rapid Pace while their body is just so
elegant there's the sense of Stillness
and confidence and integrity that's
missing in the in the White House video
it's it looks like an elementary tap
class where every movement is just so
exaggerated in the biggest Smiles it
actually looks like the scene in Singing
in the Rain with Jean Kelly
where it's a flashback
to uh to Jean Kelly's bad days doing the
Vaudeville circuit you know fit as a
fiddle ready for
love and it's where all of the uh the
mannerisms are exaggerated and it's it's
a funny scene it's a delightful scene
but it's funny in that what he's doing
here is expressing a bad
dance that's what's going on here and
and it's just true of all of our modern
politics there's no sense anymore of
understatement of Elegance of humility
of of subtlety that's gone now
everything has to be so exaggerated
everyone has to be so uh prideful and
over-the-top and constantly drawing
attention to themselves in in
unattractive ways that's that's what I
don't like about it but I do like I do
like the tap dancing I just think about
today how many more exclamation points
you see in correspondence in the old
days in the days of Jee Kelly Fred a
stair Gregory hin Sammy Davis Jr people
rarely used exclamation points in their
correspondence because an exclamation
point is like laughing at your own joke
it's an exclamation point is like this
White House tap dancing
video it
it's it's so unnecessary it's so
gratuitous today if you send a text
message or even a professional email
without 75 exclamation points people are
going to think you're a sociopath
they're going to think you're a stone
cold
killer it gets to that that underlying
rot then the final problem with the
White House tap dancing video is I don't
I don't think they were actually
recording the Taps I think those Taps
were added in after the fact I'm not
positive but the Taps don't really seem
to line up with the foot movements but
because the White House is just not
wired for tap dancing it's not like a
big tap stage in any case a good idea I
want to give the Biden White House I Joe
Biden was the one who posted this uh I
want to give them credit for having a
nice impulse but you got to land the
execution too they did not man what a
great clip that was now hold up hold up
hey hold up ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael nolles podcast we'll see you
next time